s'il n'y a vraiment plus d'argent et
même plus de musique pour les kings
gueule bien entendu attention je vous
donne la réponse ou me donner la réponse
geneviève de fontenay geneviève de
fontenay
geneviève de fontenay vite la question
oui oui quel candidat soutient geneviève
de fontenay geneviève de fontenay
quelqu'un disait que c'était ce coup de
pied sur
la question et c'est quelqu'un qui la
soutient
mais non
d'accord
je me rends compte s'attaque au cerveau
non mais vraiment c'est un truc de fou
un bébé naît
de zaki est fier l'ancien président mais
je ne viens de tourner mais on s'en fout
de ça n'est pas de nature délicate et la
réponse mais pas du tout aller manger
des crevettes toi
madagascar oui père noël qu'elle quelles
personnalités annoncées récemment pour
qui elle allait voter mais non personne
à tuer on rit
non mais non oui ben ali quelle
personnalité intervenons les gens
non non c'est
[Applaudissements]
xavier bertrand et bien ces jeunes vient
de vendée qui est invité chez radio dans
la presse que c'est la question
j'adore c'est avec un pote à moi qui ai
x38 avec vous je la dois me hugot grands
lacs je
l'aurais devant laquelle arrive et
qu'elle voterait pour xavier bertrand
j'adore hugo d'un gros talon est mon ami
bah voyons pas bah ouais c'est fou vous
avez des amis de vingt ans
bien sûr oui mais plein de gaston-pams
un cougar
est ce que vous savez ce que vous avez
déjà une idée de pour qui vous allez
voter en 2022 en 2022 ah non
pour l'instant on fait si c'est
quelqu'un que je connais depuis
longtemps
et gagner bertrand lavier bertrand n'est
pas un énarque les pannes sommes
d'argent et tout il ay là il a des
qualités il pourrait redresser un peu la
france mais là sinon je me demande qui
leur arrivait
alors
les ip elle est hyper remontée moi je
parle tout le temps avec elle j'ai parlé
avec elle elle est hyper en colère elle
me dit j'en ai marre de la misère des
violences inacceptables
elle est déchaînée en ce moment est
vraiment elle veut que tout change est
elle votre vol est passé de mélenchon
si elle a changé en fait ils sont très
amis les maires il était maire de
saint-quentin pendant des années la vie
et en plus il a même assisté à
l'élection de miss prestige à saint
quentin qui est une ville magnifique
merci caselli fait un joli soutien à m
me sens assez bien non mais non mais
c'est vrai alors c'est vous que school
et à 50 ans vous j'adore saint quentin
vous avez vous avez là bas les nayar non
mais c'est surtout les autres resteront
à
jamais qui n'est jamais gratuit
fallait encore celui-ci sur les collines
à l'est réponse tu es toi tais toi et
toi tu es toi je devrais faire belle
remontée
[Applaudissements]
c'est quelqu'un qui a dit ça à un de nos
chroniqueurs
oui
oui oui oui
qu'a dit un juré je crois que c'est
chris marquès a marqué de leurs maux
chris marquès a d'ailleurs battu de
leurs mots et sa sortie sur bilal
hassani chris marquez était l'invité de
l'émission en toute intimité de samedi
rassure youtube et pendant l'interview
chris marquez est revenu sur la
polémique entre mathieu et bill à la
ceni et à glisser un petit tacle à m'a
tuer regarder on vous a résumé toute
l'histoire la
wii c'est pourtant pas la première fois
qu'on lui dit mathieu tétouan puisque
marquez a réagi lundi dans l'émission de
samira aux propos qu'a vu matthieu
delormeau sur bilal assadi dans danse
avec les stars et quand deux garçons
dans son ensemble qui dansent sébile al
hassani un mec qui a une perruque et des
fossiles je ne me reconnais pas dans ce
style de guerre pour chris marquès
juridique aux âmes de l'émission qui les
laisse à n'y a tout à fait sa place dans
le programme et il a raison d'assumer sa
différence avant même que l'émission
commence tu viens en fait critiquer la
position de bilal hassani on a un gamin
qui en fait fièrement porte qui il est
sans concession selon lui le choix de
danser avec un autre homme était un
commun accord entre bilali la production
sébile à l'envi danser avec un autre
homme et que bilal a envie de faire
danse avec les stars bilal valence avec
un autre homme c'est quoi ce délire la
prochaine fois mathieu tendre à sept
fois sa langue dans sa bouche avant de
parler ce jour là il aurait mieux fait
de se taire
et merci à samira pour les images et
merci à un match dur et ça c'est
vraiment c'est un pote je l'adoré
qu'est ce qu'il a dit dans la tonne mais
on peut avoir des potes avec qui on
n'est pas d'accord
sans rien j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de gays depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant qui vraiment ne me
disent qu'ils étaient qui sont d'accord
avec moi et puis encore une fois je
remets rien sur bilal hassani qu'un très
beau parcours vraiment lui je n'ai rien
contre lui je redis ce que j'ai dit et
c'est vrai et en plus paraît-il que tf1
a dit il ya un moment il va danser en
garçon avec un garçon bon j'attends
toujours donné aux quatrième cinquième
prime il est toujours il est toujours en
femme ça ça me dérange pas mais ans mais
encore une fois je redis la même chose
c'est que pour le moment bah tf1 fait
non c'est un garçon avec une femme en
nous faisant croire que c'est un garçon
que c'est là que ça avec moi c'est toi
qui es tu le vois que ça mais répétition
il
faut les bagues et de la danse de la
danse qui ne l'ont pas fait à des
magnétos quand même il est illettré la
très à l'aise aussi bien habillés en
garçons cabinet en vol mais encore une
fois ce que je dis c'est normal c'est
que je ne critique pas du tout on peut
on peut être mon genre et on peu tôt
mais je redis juste la même chose c'est
que malheureusement à la télévision la
télévision c'est un c'est un stabilo la
télévision c'est toujours caricatural et
quand on montre à un gay à la télévision
faut systématiquement que ce soit une
caricature on l'avait vu dans dans
l'émission avec benjamin bove je peux
comment s'appelait les couvrir les coûts
et toutes ces émissions de pascal guéret
entre guillemets homme normal avec un
autre c'est pas l'affairé et c'est pas
bon il sait tout commence parce que les
deux personnages garçon qui est qu ici
tout va mal
oui
tu as raison c'est vrai que c'est pas
non plus on est passé tout n'avait
encore une fois il ya j'écoute bien
qu'ils accord avec mathieu tu dis aux
normales normal y'a pas de normalité est
vraiment lui-même reconnaît mais
vraiment lui-même ses prêts à voter les
rues aussi non mais je le vous j'ai vu
voilà il est il et il est heureux comme
il est il a envie de se montrer il a
envie de on sent qu'il est dans le
changement y monaural il est maladroit
au cornouaille à la normale
je dis juste que encore une fois c'est
très caricatural et que j'ai passé le
droit j'ai droit moi de ne pas me
retrouver pour la première fois que je
trouve que tu rejettes sur lui quelques
chose toi tu as une pensée et lui il
n'aurait pas le droit d'avoir la sienne
non ça qui me gêne qui se retrouvent en
bilal et à qui fait de la foule bien ce
matin le père noël est une ordure mais
je suis complètement d'accord là dessus
rien tout regard danse avec les stars on
voit pas deux hommes qui dansent on voit
un homme et un autre homme qui a
l'apparence d'une femme à la voix là le
jour y mettrons deux hommes qui ont
l'apparence d'un us open question de
normal pas normal là on pourra dire
qu'il ya pas de malaise avec ça là y en
a clairement ils sont pas près de mettre
deux hommes avec l'apparence d'hommes en
train d'en sens exact et mieux 17 et
mieux dit merci à qui merci il résume
bien mes pensées raison un peu nerveuse
ouais ça vous avez dépensé nerveux oui
mais c'est peut-être complètement
formaté en fait ça où il a envie d'être
comme ça mais on a dit que c'est bien
six milliards d'êtres comme ça c'est que
pour la première fois qu'on voit deux
hommes dans son ensemble il faut envoyer
un message fort et universel et que là
c'est une carrière dit il
s'épanouit des pays d'agde bilal il fait
ce qu'il veut il fait ce qu'il veut
c'est lui a pas dit qu'on est en train
de dire on parle de l'image de l'image à
la télévision indique renault f1 qui
soit disant nous dit pour la première
fois en fait dans ces deux gains à
l'image quand tu regardes tu vois un
homme et pardon mais un homme qui allait
qui est inquiétant rome et qu'elle est
flou et c'est comme unique hommes grimés
en femmes je vois un homme lambda c'est
son choix lancé son cri en appétit les
débats sans joie on dit que tf1 a décidé
de faire dans celle de g
c'est un héros qui établissent une
présentation du get vous la voudriez
c'est ça qui est pas logique manger
voilà on va sur un autre sujet
gmail a le droit d'être comme quand tu
comprends quand elle allait donc
pourquoi on te reproche ce que tu
toujours
selon tendrait qu'il y a entre
guillemets gueuler bongay éléments
veegaete des gays qui gêne parce que ils
sont habillés avec ceci ou cela et des
gays qui ce qui te plairait mieux parce
qu'il serait plus normé selon tata
grille de lecture sinon quelle
créativité tout ça non c'est pas du tout
ce que je dis non non il est exclu il
explique la chose simplement c'est que
alors vous êtes vraiment devenu vraiment
reporte tous les deux puisque vous étiez
à deauville la semaine dernière torché
élections libres la jeune et je le
rejoins c'est que à la télévision quand
on met un gay dans une émission
généralement il c'est un peu une
caricature penser des queen c'est un peu
le côté à queer et où les couleurs peu
un peu les prix de bahreïn mais c'est un
peu un peu fofolle l'a élu il est dit il
est habillé en femme et il faudrait non
mais oui mais ça les grecs qui sont
denses avec
indépendance avec l homme que tu est
urgent figeant leucémie à gré des nuits
la balance avec canal avait peut-être
avril jean fugère sadrau il avait
demandé on lui a dit non hélas la seule
année où tu es fan du tout d'un coup au
bout de onze ans et un homme est alors
ben lobb le deuxième homme étant femmes
et jean pierre seignat toujours dit
qu'il n'avait pas parce qu'il n'avait
pas demandé ça vient donc la tuque des
gens c'est
vrai le connaît la téléphonie
il a démenti donc tu te qu'est ce que
t'en sais ça aussi des gens qui
chantaient
ok vous quelqu un quelque chose à
ajouter là dessus qui va gagner mais
c'est lui qui va gagner c'est sûr c'est
le meilleur gagne et bien partie oui
c'est vrai c'est vraiment une priorité
pour vous ça fait plaisir parce que dita
von teese je pensais que ce serait lé
bas c'est lui qui va gagner si vous
n'avez pas d'avis sur le mois sur le
truc non non il est un
peu de poil à pasqua non mais sur les
connaissez la bande d'arrêt d'urgence et
c'est un truc de fou d'affaires n'a
progressé là-bas on va l'appeler labbé a
eu de bons mots thiélin
le sexe réponse le sexe à le sexe sexe
oui bat kent que n'a pas cyril hanouna
ah ouais bah vous le dis tout le temps
sec cerveau stefan isis une bonne
réponse à un point mais merci cependant
d'avis que bientôt va ton enlevé j'ai vu
l'info ce matin que bientôt vas t'on on
le vend au niveau du front se
[Rires]
situe sur des passeports américains ont
produit ou prenez tout d'abord débuté au
bas tu sais pas il sait que
le trio kesa ce jeu qui passe une phrase
en français aller pour voir ce qu'il
vaut en français que moi je suis moi et
espagnols au maroc je suis né maroc oui
à gennevilliers de partout où il peut
gratter
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans deux minutes tu dis qu'un kebab a
tué
alors
que ne saurait attendre plus obligés de
l'inscrire
sexe pas la réponse de bernard montiel
et
[Applaudissements]
on ne sera plus obligé de mettre le sexe
sur le passeport on met lass c'est pour
les personnes non binaire intersexe et
plus largement celles qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans les critères de
genres proposés dont il y aura plus de
sexe voilà c'est ça il y aura plus vous
savez que ça existe déjà en australie en
nouvelle zélande l'enad hamada et
attendirent vérité au népal mais c'est
dingue il ya le canada aussi l'allemagne
l'argentine l'inde ou le pakistan qui
proposent le choix x ou autres dans leur
passeport ah oui aussi voilà en fait
j'avais dit que des pays qu'il y avait
pas
j'assure
cécile maisons vont se rapprocher par
exemple alors comme ces noms genre et
vous ne seriez pas gai moi non plus où
on voyait ce que dira ça sonne avait
qu'est ce que vous voulez
il fallait manger des c5 crevettes
à madagascar mais qu'est ce que c'est
que cette soirée
non mais c'est bon quoi non je dis j'ai
une petite chose à dire là dessus quand
même parce que ça aussi ça me choque
pardon je dois vous choque ça fait un
peu vieux combat oui parce qu'encore une
fois je suis vraiment pour que quelqu un
qu un jeune garçon ou une jeune fille
que ne se sentent pas dans le bon sexes
à la naissance qu'on les aide absolument
pour changer de sexe qui est moins de
barrières qui n'avait maintenant fallait
voir des psys des médecins c'est d'être
compliqué ça que je suis à fond pour en
revanche qu'il n'y ait plus de sexe mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire quelqu'un
aziz issa garçons quelqu'un qu'on a
passé une fille gothique mais tu te sens
tu te sens aussi bien fichu garçon tu
mets ça n'existe pas bassignana plein
qui le délit n'est qu'ils se sentent
comme ça peut-être que toi c'est une
énigme pour toi mais ça existe pour
beaucoup de gens j'avais quoi
non mais c'est pas je ne comprends pas
me suis peut-être le seul âgé verde trop
binaire en fait tu n'as pas de nuances
tu peux pas comprendre que des gens
effectivement qu'ils n'ont pas envie de
choisir qui se sentent entre les deux
toi c'est normal pas normal comme ça
comme ça on est de l'ormeau on n'est pas
de l'ormeau non il ya des gens qui sont
pas toi qui sont eux-mêmes et qu'ils
aient envie d'être dans une autre ville
sont pas hommes ils sont pas et quand
ils cocher une case il était malheureux
on va enfin les rendre new dirige te
sens plus d'accord avec mathieu toi non
c'est bien que ces personnes qui sont
une minorité mais qu'ils aient une
certaine reconnaissance et qu'ils
puissent formaliser sur leur passeport
s'ils ne se sentent ni homme ni femme et
contrairement à ce que dit eric zemmour
c'est pas parce qu'on interdit à
certains enfants ou adolescents de dire
qu'ils se sentent mon genre et que ça va
complètement déréglé la société c'est
une minorité certes mais il faut la
respecter moi je mets le film je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec guillaume
merci
d'accord avec john parce
qu'effectivement ces gens qui se
sentaient mal à l'aise s'exile alors
lors de lors des papiers voilà et ben
enfin ils pourront aujourd'hui benjamin
castaldi qui met les gaz
[Rires]
je vais la raison de
cette place là cette fois la personne et
2 orienté
on a vraiment l'impression qu'elle a été
quasi non mais franchement ces bouquins
salle du non pas du tout non mais
franchement y arrière problème il doit y
avoir un truc sur cette chaise
effectivement haut niveau dans ce sens
je pense que c'est à côté
valérie va bien
qu'on aide les gens qui sont perdus à
choisir leur sexe ou leur sexualité
aucun souci mais ça veut dire que tu vas
rencontrer quelqu'un j'ai pas le lundi
au bureau bonjour tu es un homme ou
femme du nom on au foot ou semble
indiqué mardi suit femmes qui
soutiennent uni noir ni blanc tu métis
là c'est pareil à valeur actualisée tu
peux être ni homme ni femme tuer tuer
des genres et moi je crois qu'avec ces
sonneries ces personnes différentes
c'est une question de respect de dignité
pour elle c'est très important c'est ni
homme ni femme née notre case maintenant
ce sera xxl c'est bien c'est la dignité
et du respect amélie je respectais pas
certaine mais j'ai jamais dit ça au
ricard mathieu le
dour à doha gnouf les shérifs 379 la
réponse croissance ou sandales
379 mais alors quel est le nombre de
chroniqueurs de tpm pea
on va dire 378 pages qui viendra
à oui on aura combien en bonus pour le
lundi 1er novembre ouais pas mal non on
n'a pas de bonus combien de personnes
ont regardé ouf
je prends
c'est un rapport avec la mort non mais
le nombre de morts on dîne c'est un
nombre de bars nombreuses morts oui j'ai
eu à hu est alors c'est qui oui non oui
oui oui
les fines je ne sais pas a bola
salut ma démission
je sais l'émission est elle dit combien
de personnes sont décédées en faisant la
selphy
[Applaudissements]
160 personnes sont mortes ces dernières
années en faisant un self et c'est la
mort quand même la plus con hôpital
imaginez regardez c'est un depuis 2008
dans le monde au moins 3 179 amateurs
d'autoportraits sont décédés l'étude
rapporte que c'est l'inde qui est loin
devant en première place de ce triste
palmarès avec 100 morts depuis 2008 des
chiffres qui s'expliquent en partie dit
la fondation par le fait que beaucoup de
personnes prennent des selphy là bas
voilà ça les deux celle ci je vous la
montre parce que ce couple s'en est
sorti sans de bobo grave ils ont à peine
été hospitalisé mais on trouve des
vidéos horrible comme ça où on voit les
derniers instants en direct de plus en
plus de monde désormais c'est fou la
voir les delanes parce que j'ai vu ce
matin et en fait c'est que ce sont les
gens en inde vous savez les trains sont
sur bondé et ils se prennent tous en
photo la tuer comme ça sur le côté et
ils se prennent cette année d'un accord
c'est le record se remémore la côte du
train quel code c'est surtout des jeunes
24 ans de moyenne d'âge
et alors il ya des chutes il ya même eu
des noyades des gens qui sont morts
noyés en faisant à ses deux filles
comment ils ont reculé tant qu'ils n'ont
pas vu la mère est arrivée sont morts
n'ont absolument rien et une trentaine
avec des animaux sauvages hawaï et noyer
ah ouais c'est fou voilà des chutes dans
des accidents la route est loin des
messages aux armes à feu et à la suite
d' attaques d'animaux
à niveau et on prenait un univers alors
c'est vrai rien à voir avec les morts
parce que c'est pas parce que c'est pas
aussi grave mais c'est drôle quand on
dit ça parce qu'hier quand j'ai fait mon
selphy des crevettes de madagascar yann
clairay café
tu vas nous faire un nom à des crevettes
s'est tranquillement avec mes crevettes
de madagascar
je trouve cette idée alors qu'il ne
restait pas assez le film et j'ai pris
comme ça j'ai reculé un peu me suis
retourné le placard était ouvert et non
mais je me suis cogné
de l'acrobate
non je vois ce n'est pas le fourre à
pâtisserie
[Rires]
non non non non alors vous êtes fait mal
bah évidemment mais s'accordent sur
blogger eux sont toutes en forme et 40
trouvé voilà exactement d'enfants
handicapés des séries pas de gros dégâts
exactement bien sûr tout cas très belles
anecdotes taxer la failli mourir en
faisant celle ci n'en craint d'isabelle
eux n'ont personne pour bientôt mais
arrêtez isabelle vous êtes la plus jeune
d'entre nous sans rigoler personnes
violentes ont même pas ne prend jamais
en photo au réseau physique atypique
à coups mais il me donne beaucoup de sel
fille
elle est bien
mais
qu'est ce qu'on veut c'est la nuit 30 à
la salle de bain et
puis la neuro machin ça vous dérange pas
du tout j'ai regardé j'ai posé en photo
j'en ai fait des rideaux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]